hello there it's a new week in fortnite
and with it comes another update adding
a handful of things to the game like
usual we're going to look at these and
find the links to the storyline of
chapter three so sit your butt down for
five minutes slapping code adamaru to
give my life purpose and let's do this
over the last month the snow has slowly
been pushed back by warmer weather and
finally tilted towers has returned four
years and one day since it was revealed
in chapter one one of the most beloved
places for frag hunters this version of
tilted is a blend of og parts and a few
updated assets too it definitely feels
more modern here the fireside court has
been renovated some of the roads and
pavements are much more shinier and
pete's pizza pit is looking better than
ever for me though the real wow moment
is the return of no sweat insurance this
building has so much history behind it
it was renowned for constantly being
destroyed and rebuilt over and over
again in chapter one this was until the
great volcano blast of may 2019. the
entirety of tilted towers was blown up
that day except for one building the no
sweat insurance building inside they
erected a diorama it's identical to the
one we saw in 2019 and depicts the
history of fortnite from the asteroids
which splashed down to the visitors
rocket which we all thought was going to
destroy tilted towers and then the day
kevin the cube rolled through the poi
and of course the volcano blast 2. a
nice piece of history to the weird story
we just can't get enough of and another
reference that history is repeating
itself it may be worth noting there's a
crane in the waters outside tilted too i
don't remember seeing it in chapter one
so i'm guessing this is more important
in future weeks and like usual i'll let
you know if anything changes
the next update is found a little
further east a new landmark has appeared
the devoured you'll recognize this place
right away if you've been playing
fortnite for a few years but if not i
shall break it down this new location is
a dig site archaeologists are excavating
a fossil of some sort but we know
exactly what it is they are digging up
the remains of the devourer the polar
peak monster a key villain found in
chapter one when we jumped forward in
time and neo tilted was created a frozen
beast was spotting falling out in the
mountains that thing escaped and began
swimming in the water circling the
island until the day it came and
attacked the zero point hidden inside
the bolt the beast didn't bank on
resistance and a huge megazord was
created and rescued us all finally
taking out the polar peak monster with a
huge sword which was disguised as a
statue the sword stood proudly over the
corpse until we were thrown into a black
hole and now three years later the bones
have definitely seen better days and the
sword is now completely missing so let's
start to predict the future what do you
think will happen next it's largely
believed singularity was the woman
controlling the mech that day that
defeated the monster but following that
fight she left and ventured into space
and since then we found out a bit more
law about the island although it's flat
it's still technically a planet floating
out in space this suggests singularity
is out there somewhere we also know that
the scientist has been pinging another
member of the seven called the paradigm
and many of us believe she is
singularity the narratives over the
years are now starting to entwine and
also keep in mind the mech's arm from
that fight is currently in the water on
the west side of the island too this
cannot be a coincidence something is
going to happen with the mech and the
monster again could this be a way for
the scientist to bring back paradigm to
the seven or will the fallen beast
somehow rise up again for round two
prompting singularity to return in her
one armed mech i cannot wait to find out
i'm getting live event vibes right now
though it's simply an excavation site
which we will keep an eye on each week
as they delve deeper so please click
subscribe because i'd really like to get
to 2 million subs this year and impress
my mum
before we talk about this sexy being we
first need to look at the i o update and
their attempts to burrow through the
island and join us on the flip side so
we know io are planning five scouting
missions to our side of the island and
right now there are two here but there
are a few changes at each location you
should definitely see for yourself each
of the drills has now opened up to
reveal this piece of tech a kind of
listening device maybe some sort of
scanner or satellite transmission where
we can actually interact with a nearby
computer which was also updated today
push the button and you'll be given a 60
second i o scan of nearby living beings
and objects io are not rushing into a
battle with the seven and instead are
using reconnaissance and scouting
missions to analyze this new world of
threats and potential weaknesses and
that brings us nicely on to colombos a
new type of dinosaur is roaming around
the island this unique species of dino
have been hibernating since the island
flipped and now the snow is melting they
have awoken and are now enjoying a
stroll around these chaps are ravenous
and will eat loot so be careful what you
leave on the ground clumbos have this
cool trick which sees their blowhole
eject a weapon after overeating making
them a walking loot chest also a quick
tip if you need to relocate quickly you
can use that blowhole for a quick escape
just don't annoy them they get angry and
our bullets only do one damage in fact i
challenge you can you take out a columbo
and live to tell the tale a cool trick
the colombos have is the ability to
change colour this happens when they get
mad they go red but they also change
when they eat clum berries another thing
added today clumbos can also walk
through buildings and structures like
they weren't there they simply don't
care they want to eat after a long
hibernation other things of note in this
week's update are the addition of names
to some of the smaller pois like the
john wick looking house is now called
the sandblast estate and there's three
or four of these around the map now so
it's safe to say some things will happen
at each of these smaller pois later in
the chapter so how did i do what did i
miss have you spotted any small updates
yet this chapter if you do please let me
know because those are my favorite
things to look for in fortnite i'm adam
you're awesome here's a bunch of legends
used my code this week thank you kindly
appreciate you i'll see you next time
see ya
[Music]